il ya quelque chose qui a beaucoup
compliqué la faire c'est la
retransmission du discours par lci
exactement que je ne m'explique toujours
pas parce qu'on est passé d'un cadre
presque privé a tout d'un coup
l'expression publique bons mets donc se
trouve que ça complique un peu la chose
après dans l'émission qui passe ce soir
c'est pour ça que je vais vous quittez
s'est vite juste après le débat j'ai
recadré et moore je vous ai dit ce que
je pensais de son intervention je lui ai
dit les points qu'ils m'avaient non
seulement déçu mais choqué que je
trouvais inadmissible à commencer par la
comparaison entre le nazisme et l'islam
et il ya eu un communiqué de la de la
chaîne qui a été lu et qui a fixé à
azemmour les deux limites c'est à dire
qui ne peut pas être à la fois
chroniqueurs et homme politique ne peut
pas franchir les limites de la loi
alors est-ce qu'il va tout perdre moi je
dis non parce que ça dépend de lui
maintenant ça dépend de lui s'il ne
respecte pas ces deux limites je pense
que rabat d'autres avertissements plus
deuxième jaune sera un rouge
c'est la position de la chaîne moi je ne
suis pas juge
donc paris première dans le groupe m6
lui aurait dit est d'ailleurs r d asie
et arte elle aussi est dans le groupe à
ce titre c'est la dernière fois
la prochaine fois tu sors le communiqué
aller dans ce sens-là s'était pas
exprimé en ces termes à la voilà moi je
dis simplement que n'étant ni juge ni
présidents de chaînes moi ma seule
fonction c'est de contredire ces mots je
laisse aux autres le soin de déterminer
si ça tombe sous le coup de la loi ou
s'il doit rester à l'antenne mais je
fais ce boulot et je les fais qu'une
particulière vigueur dans l'émission qui
passe ce soir